about everybody okay
well good afternoon everyone today
i'm pleased to announce nominations and
staff for
critical foreign policy national
security positions in my administration
it's a team that will keep our country
and our people
safe and secure it's a team that
reflects the fact that
america is back ready to lead the world
not retreat from it once again sit at
the head of the table
ready to confront our adversaries and
not
reject our allies ready to stand up for
our values
in fact in calls from world leaders that
i've had about 18 of them are 20 so far
i'm not sure the exact number
in the week since we've won the election
i've been struck
by how much they're looking forward to
the united states
reasserting its historic role as a
global leader
both in the pacific as well as the
atlantic
all across the world the team meets this
moment
this team behind me they embody my core
beliefs that america is strongest
when it works with its allies
collectively
this team has secured some of the most
defining national security and
diplomatic achievements
in recent memory made possible through
decades of experience
working with our partners that's how we
truly keep america safe
without engaging in needless military
conflicts
and our adversaries in czech and
terrorists at bay
and that's how we counter terrorism and
extremism
control this pandemic and future ones
deal with the climate crisis nuclear
proliferation
cyber threats and emerging technologies
that spread authoritarianism
and so much more and while this team has
unmatched experience and accomplishments
they also reflect the idea that we
cannot meet these challenges with old
thinking
and unchanged habits for example
we're going to have the first woman lead
the intelligence community
the first latino an immigrant to lead
the department of homeland security
and a groundbreaking diplomat at the
united nations
we're going to have a principle on the
national security council's full-time
job
is to fight climate change for the first
time
ever that will occur and my national
security team
will be coordinated by one of the
youngest national security advisers in
decades
experience and leadership fresh thinking
and perspective
and an unrelenting belief in the promise
of america
i've long said that america leads not
only by the example of our power
but by the power of our example
and i'm proud to put forward this
incredible team
that will lead by example
as secretary of state i nominate tony
blinken
he's one of the better prepared for this
job no one's better prepared in my view
he will be the secretary of state who
previously served in top rolls on
capitol hill
in the white house and in the state
department
he delivered for the american people in
each place
for example leading our diplomatic
efforts in the fight against isis
strengthening america's alliance and
positions the in the age of pacific
guiding our responses to the global
refugee crisis with compassion
and determination and he will rebuild
morale and trust in the state department
where his career where his career in
government began
and he starts off with the kind of
relationships around the world
that many of his predecessors have had
to build over the years
i know i've seen him in action tony's
been one of my closest and most trusted
advisors
i know him and his family immigrants and
refugees
a holocaust survivor who taught him to
never take for granted
the very idea of america as a place
of possibilities possibilities
tony is ready on day one
as secretary for homeland security i
nominate alejandro
mayorkas this is one of the hardest jobs
in government
a gigantic agency the dhs secretary
needs to keep us safe
from threats at home and from abroad and
it's
and it's the job that plays a critical
role in fixing our broken immigration
system
after years of chaos dysfunction
absolute cruelty at dhs
i'm proud to nominate an experienced
leader who has been hailed by both
democrats and republicans
ali as he goes by as a former u.s
attorney
former director of u.s citizenship and
immigration services
and a former dhs dhs deputy
secretary helped implement daca
prevented attacks on the homeland
enhanced our cyber security helped
communities recover
from natural disaster combat it ebola
and zika
and while dhs affects everyone given its
critical role in immigration matters i'm
proud
that for the first time ever the
department be led by an immigrant
a latino who knows that we are a nation
of laws
and values and one more thing
today's his birthday happy birthday man
happy birthday
he's 21.
as a director of national intelligence i
nominate
avril haynes the first woman ever to
hold this post
to lead our intelligence community i
didn't pick a politician or a political
figure
i picked a professional she's eminently
qualified
former deputy director of the cia former
deputy national security adviser to
president obama
and a fierce advocate for telling the
truth
and leveling with her decisions
with the decision makers straight up
nothing unnecessary i know because i've
worked with her for over a decade
brilliant humble can talk literature and
theoretical physics fixing cars
flying planes running a bookstore cafe
all in a single conversation because
she's done all that
and above all she gets word
of a threat if she gets word of a threat
coming to our shores
like another pandemic or foreign
interference in our elections
she will not stop raising alarms until
the right people take action
people will be able to take her word
because she always calls it as she sees
it
i believe we are safer with avril on the
watch
i think we think she can make a great
contribution
and as united ambassador the united
states ambassador united nations line
emanate linda thomas
greenfield a seasoned a distinguished
diplomat
with 35 years in the foreign service who
never forgot where she came from
growing up in segregated louisiana the
eldest of eight her dad couldn't read or
write
but she says he was the smartest person
she knew
first in her family to go to to graduate
from high school
then college the whole world literally
ahead of her as her dad and mom taught
her to believe
post in switzerland pakistan kenya the
gambia
nigeria jamaica liberia
where she was known as the people's
ambassador
willing to meet with anyone an
ambassador a student
working people struggling to get by and
always treating them with the same level
of dignity
and respect she was our top state
department official in charge of african
policy during the ebola crisis
she received overwhelming support from
her
fellow career foreign service officers
and she'll be a cabinet status
because i want to hear her voice on
all the major foreign policy discussions
we have
and my national security advisor i
choose jake sullivan
he's once in a generation intellect with
experience and temperament
for one of the toughest jobs in the
world
when i was vice president he served as
my national security advisor
he was a top adviser to secretary of
state clinton
he helped lead the early negotiations
that led to the iran nuclear deal
he helped broker the gaza ceasefire in
2012
played a key role in asia pacific
rebalance in our administration
and in this campaign for the presidency
he served as one of my most trusted
advisors
on both foreign and domestic policy
including help me develop our coven 19
strategy
jake understands my vision that economic
security
is national security and it helps steer
what i call a foreign policy
for the middle class for families
like his growing up in minnesota where
he was raised by parents who were
educators
and taught him the values of hard work
decency
service and respect what that means
is to win the competition for the future
we need to keep us safe and secure
and build back better than ever we need
to invest in our people
sharpen our innovative edge unite the
economic might of our democracies around
the world to grow
the middle class and reduce inequity and
do things like
counter predatory trade practices that
are competitors and
of our competitors and our adversaries
and
before i talk about the final person
today
let me talk about this new position for
the first time ever the united states
will have a full-time
climate leader who participate in in
ministerial
level meetings and that's a fancy way of
saying
they'll have a seat at every table
around the world
for the first time ever he will be there
will be a principal
on the national security council who can
make sure climate change is on the
agenda
in the situation room for the first time
ever
will have a presidential envoy on
climate
he will be matched with high-level white
house climate policy coordinator and
policy-making structure
to be announced in december and that
will lead efforts here in the united
states to combat the climate crisis
mobilize action to meet the existential
threat that we face
let me be clear i don't for a minute
underestimate the difficulties
of meeting my bold commitments to
fighting climate change
but at the same time no one should
underestimate for a minute my
determination
to do just that and as for the man
himself
if i had a former secretary of state who
helped negotiate the paris climate
accord or a former presidential nominee
or former leading senator or the head of
a major climate organization
for the job i would show mike that would
show my commitment to
the united states and the whole world
the fact that i
pick the one person who is all of these
things
speaks unambiguously to my commitment
the world will know that with one of my
closest friends john kerry
he's speaking for america on one of the
most
pressing threats of our time known i
trust more
to this team i thank them for accepting
this call to service
and for their families i thank you all
for your sacrifice
you know we could do uh we cannot do
this without you in my view
together these public servants will
restore america globally
its global leadership and its moral
leadership
and will ensure that our service members
diplomats and intelligence professionals
can do their job free of politics
they'll not only repair though also
reimagine american foreign policy and
national security for the next
generation
and they'll tell me what i need to know
not what i want to know
what i need to know to the american
people
this team will make us proud to be
americans
and as more states certify the results
of this election
there's progress to wrap up our victory
you know i'm pleased to have received
the ascertainment from gsa
to carry out a smooth and peaceful
transition of power
so our teams can prepare to meet the
challenges at hand
to control the pandemic to build back
better
and to protect the safety and security
of the american people
and to the united states senate i hope
these
outstanding nominees received a prompt
hearing
and that we can work across the aisle in
good faith to move forward for the
country
let's begin that work to heal and unite
to heal and unite america as well as the
world
i want to thank you all may god bless
you may god protect our troops and now i
turn this over
this new team starting with our next
secretary of state
tony blinken get my mask here tony so i
don't get in trouble
and we're going to clean off the podium
good afternoon president-elect
vice president harris thank you
for your trust and your confidence
if confirmed by the united states senate
i will do everything i can
to earn it mr president-elect
working for you having you as a mentor
and friend
has been the greatest privilege of my
professional life
so many people have brought me to this
day from college classmates
to bandmates my colleagues in the
clinton and obama administrations
in the senate and at the state
department
i thank them all and i ask forgiveness
for my insatiable appetite for bad puns
mostly i'd like to thank my family
sisters and sisters in law
brothers in law nieces and nephews
my wonderful in-laws the ryans and
especially
my wife evan ryan and our children john
and lila
they are truly my greatest blessings
for my family uh as for so many
generations of americans
america has literally been the last best
hope
on earth my grandfather maurice lincoln
fled pogroms in russia and made a new
life in america
his son my father donald lincoln served
in the united states air force
during world war ii and then as a united
states ambassador
he is my role model and my hero
his wife vera blinken fled communist
hungary as a young girl
and helped future generations of
refugees come to america
my mother judith pizar builds bridges
between america and the world
through arts and culture she is my
greatest
champion and my late stepfather
samuel pizarro he was one of 900
children
in his school in viable stock poland but
the only one
to survive the holocaust after four
years in concentration camps
at the end of the war he made a break
from a death march into the woods in
bavaria
from his hiding place he heard a deep
rumbling sound
it was a tank but instead of the iron
cross
he saw painted on its side a
five-pointed white star
he ran to the tank the hatch opened
an african-american gi looked down at
him
he got down on his knees and said the
only three words that he knew in
english that his mother taught him
before the war god
bless america that's who we are
that's what america represents to the
world however imperfectly
now we have to proceed with equal
measures
of humility and confidence humility
because
as the president-elect said we can't
solve all the world's problems alone
we need to be working with other
countries we need their cooperation
we need their partnership but also
confidence
because america at its best still has a
greater ability than any other country
on earth
to bring others together to meet the
challenges of our time
and that's where the men and women of
the state department foreign service
officers
civil servants that's where they come in
i've witnessed their passion
their energy their courage up close
i've seen what they do to keep us safe
to make us more prosperous
i've seen them add luster to a word that
deserves our respect
diplomacy if confirmed it will be the
honor of my life
to help guide them and so thank you all
and may god bless america
good afternoon mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect thank you for
placing your trust in me to lead the
department of homeland security
thank you for the privilege of returning
with the consent of the senate
to government service as a member of
your administration
it is the honor of a lifetime
the department of homeland security has
a noble mission
to help keep us safe and to advance our
proud history
as a country of welcome there are more
than 240
000 career employees who selflessly
dedicate
their talent and energy to this mission
many risk their lives in doing so
i would be honored to return to the
department
and support these dedicated public
servants in fulfilling their
responsibilities
and realizing our country's greatest
hopes
all in partnership with the communities
we serve
for 12 years i had the privilege to
stand in a federal courtroom
and announce alejandro mayorkas on
behalf of the united states of america
the words on behalf of the united states
of america
meant everything to me and to my parents
whom i think of today and every day
my father and mother brought me to this
country to escape
communism they cherished
our democracy and were intensely proud
to become united states citizens
as was i
i have carried that pride throughout my
nearly 20 years of government service
and throughout my life my parents are
not here to see this day
mr president-elect madam
vice president-elect please know that i
will work day
and night in the service of our nation
to ably lead the men
and women of the united states
department of homeland security
and to bring honor to my parents and to
the trust you have placed in me
to carry your vision for our country
forward thank you
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i am grateful and even more so humbled
by the trust that you placed in me for
this role
i'm especially honored to be standing
not only by your side
but also alongside some of the most
talented and inspiring public servants
this country has ever seen
i know mr president-elect and madam vice
president-elect
that you have selected us not to serve
you but to serve on behalf of the
american people
to help advance our security our
prosperity our values
that the call to service in this role is
what makes this nomination
such a tremendous honor if afforded the
opportunity to do so
i will never forget that my role on this
team is unique
better than that of a policy advisor i
will represent to you congress
and the american public the patriots who
comprise
our intelligence community mr
president-elect
you know that i have never shied away
from speaking truth to power
and that will be my charge as director
of national intelligence
i've worked for you for a long time
and i accept this nomination knowing
that you would never want me to do
otherwise
and that you value the perspective of
the intelligence community
and that you will do so even when what i
have to say may be inconvenient or
difficult
and i assure you there will be those
times
and finally to our intelligence
professionals the work you do
often times under the most austere
conditions
imaginable is just indispensable
it will become even more complex because
you will be critical
to helping this administration position
itself
not only against threats such as cyber
attacks or terrorism and the
proliferation of nuclear biological or
chemical weapons
but also those challenges that will
define the next generation
from climate change to pandemics and
corruption
and it would be the honor of a lifetime
to be able to work alongside you once
again
to take these challenges on together
thank you so much
good afternoon mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect
i'm humbled and honored by the trust
that you have placed in me
to become a member of your cabinet as
ambassador
to the united nations in the years that
i've worked in government
i'm always struck by how only in america
would we be where we are today where
life can be hard and
cruel but there's hope in the struggle
there is promise in our dreams where you
learn
to believe in yourself and that anything
is possible like both of you
i learned from my family mr
president-elect
thank you for those generous words that
you said about me
my parents had very little back in
louisiana where i grew up but they gave
me and my siblings
everything they had and i know how proud
they would be
of this day on this day i'm also
missing my mentor ambassador ed perkins
who served as the u.s ambassador to the
united nations
under president george h.w bush and
president clinton
and who was also from louisiana he told
me constantly
linda don't undersell yourself
and he would always do everything
possible to lift me up
he passed away last week but i know he's
here with us today
and on this day i'm thinking about the
american people
my fellow career diplomats and public
servants around the world
i want to say to you america is back
multilateralism is back diplomacy
is back mr president-elect
i've often heard you say how all
politics is personal
and that's how you build relationships
of trust and bridge disagreements
and find common ground and in my 35
years in the foreign service across four
continents
i put a cajun spin on it i called it
gumbo diplomacy wherever i was posted
around the world i'd invite people of
different backgrounds and beliefs to
help me make a roux and chop onions for
the holy trinity
and and make homemade gumbo
it was my way of breaking down barriers
connecting with people
and starting to see each other on a
human level
a bit of lanyapp is what we say in
louisiana
that's the charge in front of us today
the challenges we face
a global pandemic the global economy
the global climate change crisis mass
migration and extreme poverty
social justice are unrelenting
and interconnected but they're not
unresolvable
if america is leading the way thank you
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
thank you mr president-elect i am
honored and humbled
by the immense responsibility that you
placed in me
of being your national security advisor
i pledge to you
and to the american people that i will
work relentlessly
in service of the mission you have given
us to keep our country and our people
safe
to advance our national interests and to
defend our values
i pledge to the exceptional national
security team you see behind me
and to the brilliant and diverse career
professionals across our government
that i will manage a humane and rigorous
decision-making process
that honors their work and i pledge to
my parents
who taught my brothers my sister and me
to work hard
tell the truth and serve others that i
will do my utmost to make you proud
sir we will be vigilant in the face of
enduring threats
from nuclear weapons to terrorism but
you have also tasked us with reimagining
our national security
for the unprecedented combination of
crises we face
at home and abroad the pandemic the
economic crisis
the climate crisis technological
disruption
threats to democracy racial injustice
and inequality in all forms the work of
the team behind me today
will contribute to progress across all
of these fronts
you have also tasked us with putting
people at the center of our foreign
policy
you've told us that the alliances we
rebuild the institutions we leave the
agreements we sign
all of them should be judged by a basic
question will this make life better
easier safer for families across this
country
our foreign policy has to deliver for
these families
and perhaps most importantly you've
tasked us with helping
unite america as you said in your
remarks
through our work to pull people together
to tackle big challenges
my wife maggie the love of my life and
my partner in all things
served as a senior advisor to senator
john mccain
she and i shared this commitment to
common ground deep in our bones
to the american people i had the honor
of serving as joe biden's national
security advisor when he was vice
president
i learned a lot about a lot about
diplomacy
about strategy about policy but most
importantly about human nature
i watched him pair strength and resolve
with humanity and empathy
that is the person america elected and
that is also
america at its best so mr
president-elect thank you for giving
this kid from the heartland
an extraordinary opportunity to serve
jesus
mr president-elect vice president-elect
harris
thank you uh mr president-elect for your
generous words
and most of all thank you for the trust
and the responsibility
of this appointment i will do all
in my power to live up to your
expectations
and to this moment for our country and
for the world
and i begin by thanking my family for
empowering me and
and encouraging me to take this task on
secretary designate lincoln we've worked
together for many years
on the foreign relations committee and
at foggy bottom
and it will be a huge pleasure to
partner with you again
you will be a terrific secretary
mr president-elect you've put forward a
bold
transformative climate plan but you've
also
underscored that no country alone
can solve this challenge even the united
states for all of our industrial
strength
is responsible for only 13 of global
commissions
to end this crisis the whole world
must come together your right
to rejoin paris on day one
and you're right to recognize that paris
alone
is not enough at the global meeting in
glasgow
one year from now all nations
must raise ambition together
or we will all fail together
and fader is not an option
succeeding together means tapping into
the best
of american ingenuity creativity and
diplomacy
from brain power to alternative energy
power
using every tool we have to get where we
have to go
no one should doubt the determination of
this president
vice president they shouldn't doubt the
determination of the country
that went to the moon cured supposedly
incurable diseases
and beat back global tyranny to beat
world war to win world war
ii this kind of crisis
demands that kind of leadership again
and president biden will provide it
the road ahead is exciting actually
it means creating millions of middle
class jobs
it means less pollution in our air ocean
it means making life healthier for
citizens across the world
and it means we will strengthen the
security of every nation
in the world in addressing the climate
crisis
president-elect joe biden is determined
to seize the future
now and leave a healing planet
to future generations 57 years ago
this week joe biden and i
were college kids when we lost the
president who inspired
both of us to try to make a difference
a president who reminded us that here on
earth
god's work must truly be our own
president joe biden will
trust in god and he will also
trust in science to guide our work on
earth
to protect god's creation mr
president-elect
and vice president-elect harris i look
forward to getting to work
thank you
thank you secretary kerry and
congratulations mr president-elect
on bringing together this extraordinary
team
i have always believed in the nobility
of public service
and these americans embody it
their lives and careers are a testament
to the dedication
sacrifice and commitment to civic
responsibility
that have strengthened our democracy and
kept america's promise alive
for more than 200 years president-elect
biden and i have long known
that when we were elected we would
inherit a series of
unprecedented challenges upon walking
into the white house
addressing these challenges starts with
getting this pandemic
under control opening our economy
responsibly and making sure it works
for working people and we also know
that our challenges will require us here
at home
to overcome those issues that
block our ability to proceed our
challenge here
is a necessary foundation for restoring
and advancing our leadership around the
world
and we are ready for that work we will
need to reassemble
and renew america's alliances rebuild
and strengthen the national security and
foreign policy institutions
that keep us safe and advance our
nation's interests
and confront and combat the existential
threat
of climate change that endangers us all
i take these issues very seriously my
whole career has been
about keeping people safe from serving
as district attorney
to california's attorney general to the
united states
senate where i have served on the
intelligence and homeland security
committees
i have come to know firsthand the
gravity of the challenges and threats
facing the united states and over the
past few months
i've also come to know the sound
judgment
expertise and character of the people
on this stage i can say with confidence
that they are to a person the right
women and men
for these critical positions and i look
forward to working alongside them
on behalf of the american people and on
behalf
of a president who will ask tough
questions
demand that we be guided by facts
and expect our team to speak
the truth no matter what
a president who will be focused on one
thing
and one thing only doing what is
best for the people of the united states
of america
when joe asked me to be his running mate
he told me about his commitment
to making sure we selected a cabinet
that looks like america
that reflects the best of our nation
and that's what we have done today's
nominees and appointees come
from different places they bring a range
of different
life and professional experiences and
perspectives
and they also share something else in
common
an unwavering belief in america's
ideals an unshakable commitment
to democracy human rights
and the rule of law and they understand
the indispensable role of america's
leadership in the world these women and
men
are patriots and public servants
to their core and they are leaders
the leaders we need to meet the
challenges of this
moment and those that lie ahead
thank you
thank you
thank you all right folks
okay
you